donald trump's impeachment trial starts
today now we're going to talk about
in a bit after the break what is the
argument that donald trump is making
about the impeachment
what is the argument that his lawyers
will make about the impeachment but
first let's talk about what should
happen in this impeachment
if this was a fair world where actions
had consequences even if you're the
president
there should be probably a secret ballot
for impeachment
so that senators would not be bullied
into uh voting to acquit merely to avoid
what might be the political consequences
there should be a secret ballot and
there should be a unanimous conviction
of donald trump
based on the evidence that we've seen
now there's a really good article an
op-ed in the hill
i hope i'm pronouncing his last name
correctly it's douglas meek
k-m-i-e-c i hope i'm pronouncing that
correctly and
douglas points out that the entire
argument that will take up the first day
in today's senate impeachment trial
which is is the impeachment trial even
constitutional that is not
the duty of the senate to determine the
duty of the senate is not to determine
whether this is constitutional first of
all it is and secondly
why would you put many non-legal
scholars
non-legal professionals in a position of
deciding about the constitutionality of
something it really doesn't make sense
what jurors in the senate should be
determining
is whether donald trump could reasonably
foresee that
the consequences of him saying it's all
rigged for a month or two months
let's go down to the capitol we're
marching down to the capital rudy
giuliani
you know trial by combat all of this
stuff could it was it foreseeable
that the uncontested reality of what
took place
was something uh that that was likely to
take place
that is what the determination
ultimately needs to be
donald trump doesn't have the law on his
side when it comes to avoiding
um impeachment because of some
constitutional issue but in any case
that's not really
what the senate should be deciding and
there is really no disagreement
about what took place on january 6th as
douglas meek points out
even trump's defense team acknowledges
the facts
of what took place on january 6th which
was a violent
uh insurrection attempt at the u.s
capitol so
then it becomes a question of really
common sense
remember this is not a court of law the
senate uh
was was it reasonable for donald trump
to foresee
what took place and it's very hard to
imagine that the answer is no
donald trump was reportedly gleeful in
the early hours of the insurrection
donald trump reportedly resisted sending
law enforcement which would have quelled
or or limited
what took place and only when donald
trump
was convinced that the political
consequences could be too grave
did he come out and give that
mealy-mouthed sort of uh
statement about oh we've got to be
peaceful and all of this stuff
so that's what should happen trump won't
be convicted
and the voting won't be by secret ballot
i was
i was actually thinking imagine that
there was a secret ballot where instead
of voting out loud publicly
senators voted secretly um imagine that
you end up with 80 votes to convict so
you know
30 republicans voted to convict but none
of them are willing to admit it you know
what would happen right they would again
start with voter fraud
supposedly 80 votes to convict and we
can't find a single republican willing
to say yes i voted to convict
but you know what it's going to be a
moot point because they're not going to
convict
and then it will be up to voters to
determine
whether they care enough to
force consequences upon these republican
senators in the 2022 election now as
a reminder when we talk about
representative democracy
a majority of americans say that donald
trump should be convicted and barred
from holding office in the future 56
percent of americans
we looked at that abc poll yesterday uh
trump's lawyers
are saying that the entire trial is
merely political theater
and the arguments that they are making
uh in their
early uh legal brief and we will see
today uh and tomorrow more so
how they actually make this case a
reality they are both
saying that uh the entire process is
unconstitutional
and that the house's impeachment vote
was extraordinarily biased
and they are going to say that this is
censorship and it's an attempt to
silence donald trump and of course
that's not what it is
donald trump was able to say whatever
the hell he wanted
and now there may be consequences to him
saying that remember free speech doesn't
mean
freedom from all consequences to your
speech one other little note
apparently trump's defense team is
planning to show clips of what they say
are examples of democrats urging
violence from last year
so i think that there's going to be a
lot of interesting moments during this
but ultimately we are going to get the
political theater is going to be trump's
defense
we are going to get an acquittal and
then ultimately we will see if the
american people decide that these
republican senators need to be held
accountable the american public
often has a short memory so i am not
particularly optimistic
that republican senators uh who have
prejudged this and already know they are
going to acquit will be held accountable
it would be nice if they were but i
don't
anticipate that and we will be live
streaming
the impeachment on the david pakman show
youtube
twitch and facebook channels i hope
you'll join me but in the meantime
let me know via twitter what you expect
to see
in this trial you can find me on twitter
at dpakman
i want to take a second to tell you
about one of our sponsors
snh masks snh masks has
everything you need when it comes to
face masks and other protective gear
for covid19 and they're giving my
audience 20
off snh masks is the company that i've
personally been going to
for face masks i love and trust the
products they sell and that's actually
why i reached out to them
about being a sponsor i've tried tons of
different face masks this year like many
of you
and i still have not found a mask that
is more comfortable
or easier to breathe in than the
washable cotton masks that they sell
it's made of a silky lightweight cloth
that feels great on the skin
has a convenient adjustable strap they
also have disposable cloth masks which
are really comfortable
as well as all of the other gear like
face shields alcohol
wipes no touch infrared thermometers and
all of their prices
are very reasonable i also love snh
masks
because they've donated over 60 000
masks to healthcare institutions
they're an excellent company shipping is
just five bucks and shipping is
free on orders over a hundred and fifty
dollars you can get there by going to
davidpakman.com
mask the link is under this video and
you can save 20
on everything in their store when you
use the coupon code
david